a murder suspect is on the run this
morning in northern Tennessee law
enforcement worked through the night
searching for kirby Wallace the 53 year
old man is accused of killing two people
during a violent crime spree that began
more than a week ago Don Dahler is in
Montgomery County Tennessee that's just
north of Nashville where the community
is on high alert today Don good morning
good morning the command post for the
manhunt is just up the road here the
Tennessee Bureau of Investigation says
20 of their agents have joined hundreds
of other law enforcement officers
combing this combination of residential
farmland and rugged woods for Kirby
Wallace he is at the very top of their
ten most wanted list they believe he
committed a series of violent crimes and
they're desperate to catch him before he
hurts anyone else he's a dangerous
person and he can get more desperate
Stewart County Sheriff Franky gray is
urging people to stay vigilant as the
manhunt intensifies for suspected
murderer Kirby Wallace we won't keep the
public number one safe and we're gonna
stay on it until we get this person
apprehended
police believe Wallace attacked a couple
in Stuart County on September 23rd he
allegedly tied them up and set their
home on fire the woman died and the man
was seriously hurt
four days later police suspect he tied
up and robbed an elderly woman in her
home in nearby Montgomery County and on
Monday police believe he shot and killed
a man and then stole his pickup truck
the truck was found crashed a few miles
away there was no one in the vehicle so
that leads us to believe that that
person is on foot at least 20 agencies
are assisting in the manhunt combing
through rugged and rural terrain
authorities say Wallace may be wearing
camouflage and is likely armed and
officers will take you home check your
house make sure everything's okay
on Monday police stopped vehicles
checked cars and escorted people to
their homes police have locked down an
approximately five mile perimeter we've
got it locked down for a reason we don't
want this person to hijack another
vehicle or harm anyone else I haven't
slept very well in past couple of nights
you're Kris kleiner lives near Monday's
carjacking he said neighbors are arming
themselves in case Wallace comes on
their property he has no care for human
life you know he took one life he took
another he can take another one
Wallace is also believed to have tied up
and robbed a woman back in May now that
woman's daughter says that he was
released from jail because her mother
unexpectedly died there is a $5,000
reward for information leading to his
capture and Don Dahler thanks Don